this video will show you what
immuno-oncology is and how it works
immuno-oncology is the study and
development of certain treatments
called immunotherapies for cancer
these treatments fight cancer by
strengthening your immune system
normally the white blood cells of your
immune system
help fight infections and disease
they recognize substances on the surface
of cells
called antigens healthy cells have
different antigens than damaged body
cells or
foreign invaders your immune cells
usually ignore the antigens on healthy
cells
but they do respond to antigens on
damaged cells and foreign invaders
some immune cells mark these antigens
for destruction
with a substance called an antibody
then other immune cells attack the cells
that have these antibodies
since cancer is made up of damaged cells
they may have antigens that your immune
cells recognize
and attack but some cancer cells have
ways to avoid destruction by your immune
cells for example
cancer cells may reduce the number of
cancer antigens
allowing them to hide from your immune
cells
a second way cancer cells avoid
destruction is through
checkpoint proteins both cancer
and immune cells may have these proteins
when they attach other immune cells
won't attack the cancer cell
a third way cancer cells avoid
destruction happens when the cancer
cells are
under attack from the immune system
during the attack
the cancer cells release certain
substances that
call in other types of immune cells
which slow down
or stop the immune response
immunotherapies have several ways they
work to help your immune system
fight cancer one way is through special
antibodies made in the lab
some of these antibodies attach to
cancer cells
they can kill the cancer cell directly
others mark the cancer cell so that your
immune cells destroy it
another group of antibodies blocks the
checkpoint
proteins this keeps them from attaching
to each other
as a result the immune cell can attack
and
kill the cancer cell still
other antibodies prevent the growth of
cancer cells
some of them block the signals that
cause new blood vessels to grow
and feed the cancer
in another type of immunotherapy some of
the immune cells that
best fight cancer are removed from the
body
the cells are taken to a lab where many
more of them are grown
then they're returned to the body to
attack the cancer
to find out more about the ways
immuno-oncology can help fight
cancer talk to your health care provider